Reconocí los roles que se me asignaron muy temprano.
Un concepto persistente que observé
que existe en nuestro idioma, en nuestros medios,
era que las mujeres no solo deben tener hijos,
se supone que los quieren.
Existía en todas partes.
Existía en la forma en que los adultos me hablaban
cuando plantearon preguntas en el contexto de "cuándo".
"Cuando te cases...".
"Cuando tengas hijos...".
Y estas reflexiones futuras siempre se me presentaron
como parte de este sueño americano,
pero siempre me pareció el sueño de otra persona.
Ya ven, un valor que siempre he entendido sobre mí
era que nunca querría tener hijos.
Y cuando era niña, cuando trataba de explicabsn esto,
esta desconexión entre sus roles y mis valores,
a menudo se reían
cómo lo hacen los adultos ante las cosas absurdas de los niños.
Y ellos me dirían a sabiendas,
"Cambiarás de opinión".
Y la gente me ha estado diciendo cosas así toda mi vida.
De lo contrario, una conversación educada puede convertirse en intrusión rápida.
"¿Tu esposo lo sabe?".
(Risas)
"¿Tus padres lo saben?".
"¿No quieres una familia?".
"¿No quieres dejar nada atrás?".
Y la palabra de moda principal al hablar de falta de hijos,
"Eso es egoísta".
Hay innumerables razones por las que una mujer puede tener
que elegir abstenerse de la maternidad,
la mayoría de ellas no se autoprioriza.
Pero todavía es socialmente aceptable vilipendiar públicamente a tales mujeres,
porque ninguna de estas razones ha llegado a la narrativa social.
Cuando era pequeña y aprendí sobre la inevitabilidad de la maternidad,
nunca me explicaron
lo común de estos factores que las mujeres consideran,
como el riesgo de transmitir enfermedades hereditarias,
el peligro de tener que suspender los medicamentos que salvan sus vidas
durante la duración de su embarazo,
preocupación por la superpoblación,
y el acceso a los recursos,
y el hecho de que hay 415 000 niños
en el sistema de cuidado de crianza en EE. UU. en cualquier momento dado.
Razones como estas, muchas más,
y el hecho de que no me gusta dejar cosas de esta magnitud al azar,
todas formaron mi decisión
para ser esterilizada quirúrgicamente.
Comencé mi investigación con entusiasmo.
Quería entender completamente
todo lo que vendría al someterse a una ligadura de trompas,
que es solo otra palabra para atar tus tubos.
Quería saber de la aprobación después,
índices de satisfacción, riesgos, estadísticas.
Y al principio, fui empoderada.
Ya ven, la forma en que la narración siempre se me ha enseñado,
Pensé que las mujeres que no querían tener hijos eran tan raras,
y luego aprendí que una de cada cinco mujeres estadounidenses
no tendrá un hijo biológico
algunas por elección, algunas por casualidad.
(Aplausos)
Pero no estaba sola.
Pero cuanto más leo, más descorazonada me siento.
Leo historias de mujeres,
tratando desesperadamente de obtener este procedimiento.
Aprendí lo común que era para las mujeres agotar sus finanzas
apelando a docenas de ginecólogos durante muchos años,
solo para ser rechazada tantas veces,
a menudo con tanta falta de respeto que simplemente se dieron por vencidas.
Las mujeres informaron que los médicos a menudo eran condescendientes
y desdeñosos de sus motivaciones,
que decían cosas como,
"Vuelve cuando estés casada y tengas un hijo".
Pero las mujeres que sí tuvieron hijos, que fueron a buscar este procedimiento,
les dijeron que eran muy jóvenes,
o no tenían suficientes hijos,
lo que es muy interesante,
porque los requisitos legales en mi estado para este tipo de cirugía eran,
"Tener al menos 21 años de edad",
"aparecer de buen juicio, actuar por cuenta propia"
y "un período de espera de 30 días".
Y estaba perpleja de poder cumplir con todos estos requisitos legales
y aún tener que enfrentar una batalla en la sala de examen
para mi autonomía corporal.
Y fue desalentador,
pero estaba decidida.
Recuerdo que me vestí tan profesionalmente en esa primera cita.
(Risas)
Me senté derecha.
Hablé claramente.
Quería darle a ese doctor toda la evidencia
de que yo no era la fecha de nacimiento en ese archivo.
Y me aseguré de mencionar cosas como,
"Acabo de obtener mi grado
y estoy postulando a estos programas de doctorado,
voy a estudiar estas cosas".
Y "mi socio a largo plazo tiene este tipo de negocio"
y "He investigado esto durante meses.
Entiendo todo al respecto, todos los riesgos".
Porque necesitaba que el médico supiera que esto no era un capricho,
no era una reacción,
no es sus 20-algo que busca salir y divertirse
sin miedo a ser golpeada...
(Risas)
que estaba apoyaba en algo integral a lo que yo era.
Y entiendo el consentimiento informado,
así que esperaba ser reeducada sobre cómo funcionaba todo, pero...
En un momento dado, la información que me fue dando me hizo sentir agendada,
entrelazada con sesgo y estadísticas infladas.
Las preguntas comenzaron a parecer interrogativas.
Al principio me estaban haciendo preguntas
que parecía buscar entender mejor mi situación,
y luego parecía que estaban haciendo preguntas para tratar de confundirme.
Me sentí como si estuviera en el estrado de los testigos, siendo interrogada.
El doctor me preguntó acerca de mi compañero.
"¿Cómo se siente él o ella acerca de todo esto?".
"Bueno, he estado con el mismo hombre durante cinco años,
y él apoya totalmente cualquier decisión que tome para mi cuerpo".
Y él dijo: "Bueno, ¿qué pasa en el futuro,
si cambias de pareja?
¿Qué sucederá cuando esa persona quiera hijos?
No sabía muy bien cómo reaccionar a eso,
porque lo que estaba escuchando
era a este doctor decirme que se supone que debo ignorar todo lo que creo
si un compañero demanda niños.
Entonces le dije que no se preocupara por eso.
Mi postura sobre la procreación siempre ha sido conversación de la primera cita.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Luego me pide que considere
cómo "en 20 años, realmente podría llegar a arrepentirte de esto"...
como si no lo hubiera hecho.
Le dije,
"Bien, si me levanto un día
y me doy cuenta, ya sabe,
que desearía haber tomado una decisión distinta,
la verdad es que solo habría eliminado un solo camino hacia la maternidad.
Nunca necesité biología para formar familia de todos modos".
(Aplausos)
Y preferiría lidiar con eso cualquier día
que lidiar con un día despertar,
dándome cuenta de que tuve un hijo
que realmente no quería o estaba preparada para cuidar.
Porque uno de estos me afecta solo a mí.
El otro afecta a un niño,
su desarrollo, su bienestar...
(Aplausos)
y los seres humanos no deben ser una apuesta.
Luego me dice por qué nadie iba a aprobar este procedimiento,
ciertamente no él,
debido a un concepto llamado paternalismo médico,
lo que le permite, como mi proveedor bien informado,
tomar decisiones por mí...
basado en su percepción de mi mejor interés,
independientemente de lo que yo, como paciente, desee o crea.
Aprovecha esta oportunidad para salir
y discutir mi caso con mi potencial cirujano,
y a través de la puerta, escucho que me describe como una niña pequeña.
Estaba tan ofendida.
Yo quería defenderme.
Quería explicar explícitamente a cada uno de estos proveedores
cómo me estaban tratando,
que era humillante y sexista,
y no tuve que tomarlo.
Pero lo tomé.
Me tragué cada palabra aguda en mi garganta,
apreté mi mandíbula, y en su lugar
respondí cada una de sus preguntas y declaraciones condescendientes.
Vine aquí buscando objetividad y apoyo
y en cambio me sentí despedida y silenciada,
y me odié a mí misma por eso.
Odiaba que permitiera que la gente me faltara el respeto en repetidas ocasiones.
Pero esta fue mi única oportunidad.
Esa fue una de las múltiples consultas a las que tuve que acudir.
En un momento dado, había visto a 5 o 6 profesionales médicos en la misma hora.
La puerta de la sala de examen se parecía más a la puerta de un auto payaso.
Ahí está mi primaria,
está su colega,
el director, bien.
Sentí que les pedía que me contagiaran de viruela
en lugar de, no sé, obtener anticonceptivos.
Pero no vacilé,
y fui persistente,
y eventualmente convencí a uno de ellos de permitir el procedimiento.
E incluso en la sala, firmando yo los formularios de consentimiento,
recibiendo inyecciones de hormonas y atando cabos sueltos,
mi doctor menea la cabeza en señal de desaprobación.
"Cambiarás de opinión".
Nunca entendí realmente
con qué fuerza esta sociedad se aferra a este rol
hasta que pasé por esto.
Experimenté de primera mano, repetidamente,
cómo las personas, ya sean proveedores médicos,
colegas, extraños,
fueron literalmente incapaces de verme siendo una mujer
separada de verme como madre.
Y siempre creí que tener hijos
era una extensión de la feminidad, no la definición.
Creo que el valor de una mujer
nunca debe ser determinado por si tiene o no un hijo,
porque eso la despoja de toda su identidad
como adulta en sí misma.
Las mujeres tienen esta increíble habilidad para crear vida,
pero cuando decimos que ese es su propósito,
eso dice que toda su existencia es un medio para un fin.
Es muy fácil olvidar los roles que la sociedad nos impone
son mucho más que meros títulos.
¿Qué pasa con el peso que viene con ellos?
la presión de cumplir con estos estándares...
el miedo asociado con cuestionarlos,
y los deseos que desechamos para aceptarlos?
Hay muchos caminos hacia la felicidad y la realización.
Todos se ven muy diferentes,
pero creo que cada uno
está pavimentado con el derecho a la autodeterminación.
Quiero que las mujeres sepan que su elección es aceptar o no la maternidad
no está de ninguna manera atada a su dignidad o identidad
como cónyuges, como adultas o como mujeres...
y hay absolutamente una elección detrás de la maternidad,
y es tuya
y solo tuya.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)